okay the problem the problem is is that
when you when you when you ask a
question about polling in American
history you have to think in terms of
how the american public was defined and
it's complicated because because you get
an interesting period the poll public
opinion would be during the period of
the American you know founding for
example and it's complicated there
because the the conception that the
founders had of the public and of the
electorate was a pretty narrow and is it
they basically deferred to the state's
rules with regard to voter eligibility
and things that's where knowing full
well that we're only we're talking about
basically white males were property
holders that's constituting the relevant
public and electorate and again that's a
public and an electorate who are have
the right who'd had at least in terms of
the family of the Republic were only
voted directly for members of the House
of Representatives and for their state
legend and for state legislatures there
was no history of voting for governor's
because during the colonial period the
British a couple states were able to had
people vote for governors but for the
most part they were appointed by the by
the crown by but Britain and then if
then if you go forward you're talking
about a kind of a narrow slice of the
electric which are basically talking
about white white men and you don't you
don't have the kind of American
democracy broader democracy that you
have today now brilliant you don't have
the full blown democracy until 1971-72
when when 18 year olds were given the
right to vote when women got the right
to vote around 19
blacks weren't fully a franchise until
after the implement the enactment and
implementation of voting rights act in
1965 so in terms of you know shirking on
my curiosity about bowling you're not
gonna you know the idea of polling women
in the in the 19th century not something
that was thought of and Pola obviously
and in those days depress and you know
various individuals might engage in
process of at least we would be called
straw polling and even then the people
who were being pulled were mostly mostly
men now that said I'd say if I have I
have I had if I had to pick pick
particular periods I think I think the
said well the Civil War period would be
interesting and only in the sense of
getting getting a sense of what people's
opinions were with a bar unit toward
toward Abraham Lincoln toward toward the
south toward record
Frederick Douglass
no what that would be that would be
interesting for me if if you ask me what
kind of pole I would like to be involved
in today anywhere in the world sorry I
would have liked and I can't do this I
would have liked to have done exit
polling after the last first round
presidential election in Egypt and the
reason I would have wanted to do that
and I had a discussion with pollsters
and students and faculty in Egypt was
the polls in Egypt were pre-election
polls were a disaster the pre-election
polls had the top five candidates the
two candidates they had in the lead were
the ones who finished fourth and fifth
ok the exit poll would have been
important to get a sense of what the
book what the nature of the electorate
actually was to see how the pre-election
polls were wrong they get a sense of
what and why voters well what voters
voted the way it would the way they did
and why as a way of kind of looking
forward to see what would happen in the
next election and to improve
pre-election polling in the upcoming
election there were no there were no
exit polls done in Egypt why weren't
they done is no but nobody was ready to
pay for